Now before we move on to the combined approach with Greg, let's do a quick
recap of the psychological therapies. Let's first start with psychodynamic
therapy. The goal of psychodynamic therapy is to uncover the repressed or
unconscious thoughts, feelings, and motives one has. The techniques of
psychodynamic therapy are things like dream interpretation, and free
association. Now let's move on to humanistic therapies. The goal of humanistic
therapy is to create conditions for optimal personal growth. The techniques for
humanistic therapy are unconditional positive regard, and empathic listening.
The goal of behavioral therapy is to change reinforcers and rewards, to change
maladaptive behavior. The techniques include classical and operate
conditioning, token economies, and systematic desensitization. The goal of
cognitive therapy is to change emotions or irrational thoughts. The technique
used in cognitive therapy is critical questioning, and challenge a person's
thoughts with logic. The goal of cognitive behavioral therapy is to change
behavior and thoughts. The technique used in cognitive behavioral therapy is to
restructure thoughts, and use incentives for acquiring more adaptive thoughts
and behaviors. There's also the use of appraisal. The goal of group therapy is
to create a support group in a community to show the person that he or she is
not alone. The technique for group therapy is something like a support group or
a 12-step program. Now that we've done a brief overview of the psychological
therapies, let's go on to Greg for our final section, which is the combined
approach.